un policier 10 passes des services
policiers des services policiers c'est
un service essentiel on ne traite plus
de moyens qui sont bien des discussions
de façon à manifester dans le
contentement on utilise des moyens qui
sont à notre disposition à la fac et
d'un certain on l'a vu dans le passé des
jeunes
voilà plusieurs années des grèves
deuxième où ses citoyens faisait l'effet
pour nous c'est clair on affecte pas
servi sa population en aucun temps être
de sa population est infectée
les policiers municipaux sont de
véritables professionnels pour faire en
sorte puisque confie l'homme qui tente
la partie patronale et syndicale
ce legs ce niveau l'indicé du
contribuable ont pas fait renifler